why are people so weird bro i do not
understand y'all going to see but
anyways y'all see who we rocking with
agent zero deshawn man what y'all know
about quran bro i got the chop
antoine
so now my boy brenda haywood overall
tough little squad man let's hop into it
first player of the game my man was
already lost
lord bruh you got to stay on the three
point line but huh damn buddy not know i
seen this like bruh
man do that j right to me but we going
to take this for an easy dime hey y'all
know the rule man if he ain't stopping
boy pull up gang
someone tell this man to get out this
sorry zone bruh don't help shawty huh
damn roger live hustling for design
but he still ended up throwing huh whack
up ah he starts off bawling because he
couldn't guard me crazy why are you
holding your nuts gotta step up keep him
still off ballin bruh now it's not even
that i do a simple pick and roll and
this man think he need to make every
adjustment in the world bruh this man
was on pause for nearly the whole damn
three minutes i probably think he was
away nah he's doing adjustments look
because i just went away because he
backed out now he ready to unpause damn
did a whole three minutes that's crazy
my question is how you do adjustments
for two and a half minutes and still let
me get open
it's just funny to me that people be
doing these adjustments and still be
getting cooked by the same move
not only that bruh i can't even call
timeouts because he sits through the
whole time out bruh it's the same time i
just showed y'all about a whole minute
and 15 seconds just went by like i do
not have this much time for you then
rhymed by the oddball back he all
balling me wasting my time so yeah you
damn right about the old ball back bro
you ain't bout to beat me like that hold
on pull out gang
dumba i'm telling y'all man quran is him
huh damn now he's just leaving my
shooters open okay huh dying at this
point he's he must be bored with life
because ain't no way now he's doubling
leaving shooters wide open i mean i
guess
54-41 he hit pause again remember i
showed y'all earlier he hit paul but he
only had 30 seconds left so now he got
no more pauses and they showed me if i
want to quit and receive a win or
continue the game i said now let me
continue the game because i want him to
quit
this man sat here for the whole three
minutes i went in the game chat and
talked to him at everything he wasn't
even listening so i was like all right
bruh next time that drink pop up again
i'm quitting y'all thought i was lying
or something bruh nah he realized just
sat here the whole three minutes but
dudes be hopping on the game just be
bored bro like ain't no way he's just
wasting my time like this i quit this
time i'm gonna receive my win bro i'm
not about to sit here all day like you
bruh ggs